bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission boxe
le verrou ahmed el moussaoui 25 ans
champion de l'union européenne des poids
welters s'est incliné aux points en
nouvelle zélande contre l'australien
jeff horn
nous recevrons l'illinois pour débriefer
son combat handball féminin le club de
montigny le bretonneux s'est incliné à
domicile contre colombelles lors de la
10e journée du championnat de nationale
2 le score 27 à 20 résumé du match à
suivre dans ce magazine
football - china ou si le coach de l'ess
sera pas quitter le club
mardi dernier il a été remplacé par
arnaud mbc1 dirigeants présents dans la
structure depuis une dizaine d'années
nous reviendrons sur cet épisode avec le
président mustapha larbaoui et puis en
fin d'émission l'essentiel du sport
yvelinois nous parlerons notamment rugby
et de la belle victoire de plaisir
contre maisons laffitte
on commence donc par de la boxe le vrai
roi ahmed el moussaoui 25 ans champion
de l'union européenne des poids welters
s'est incliné aux points le samedi 5
décembre à hamilton en nouvelle zélande
contre l'australien jeff horn évinois a
tenu jusqu'au 10e rang avec une blessure
au biceps contractée pendant le combat
face au triple champion d'australie de
27 ans le boxer surnommé à eux mêmes ne
remporte donc pas les titres
intercontinentaux ibm et wb aux
orientales pour des prêts faits ce
combat nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
sur ce plateau
le boxeur very roi ahmed el moussaoui
bonsoir mon summum qu'elle alors je le
disais précédemment vous n'avez vraiment
pas eu de chance pendant ce combat vous
avez a contacté une blessure dès le
début du combat oui c'est vrai que j'ai
contracté une blessure mais on va dire
que je les doubles et la blessure parce
que en fait en fin de compte
j'étais blessé avant de partir mais je
ne s'en est pas rendu compte avec mon
équipe puisque j'ai fait une irm avant
de partir et puis j'ai reçu les
résultats en revenant en revenant et
voilà on a vu que j'étais déjà blessé et
je pense que la blessure s'est empirée
plan de combat et donc pourquoi ne pas
avoir déclaré forfait ou le disais
précédemment vous étiez un peu blessé
avant le combat pour toi ne pas avoir
déclaré forfait tout simplement
en fait j'essaie de me soigner comme
comme il fallait
bah ça ça marche ça marche et un petit
moment puisque j'avais très bien jusqu'à
ce qu'enfin de préparation tu juste même
avant le combat
j'avais pas j'avais aucune douleur donc
c'est pour ça que voilà je me sentais
bien j'étais prêt j'étais sûr de gagner
puis l'évolution lui est ce qu'il n'ya
pas eu peut-être l'orgueil peut-être
aussi qui a joué le fait de déclarer
forfait ne vous plaît pas forcément
peut-être bien sûr après c'est vrai que
non je ne déclaraient pas forfait
mais bon on savait pas que c'était une
blessure de cette ampleur mais disons
que voilà j'ai fait ce qu'ils avaient à
faire et puis même même pendant le
combat je n'avais pas déclenché mais
j'aurais pu très bien et elle combat a
dit à mon entraîneur et j'ai mal de
choses mais voilà c'est l'orgueil aurait
qui a joué après finir au point et est
ce que le fait de boxer à l'étranger en
nouvelle zélande c'était loin est ce que
ça vous a également fatigué peut-être
avant ce combat
non non ça m'a pas fatigué le fait de
boxer à l'étranger mais c'est sûr que
j'ai eu une préparation en tout cas
d'une préparation optimale et et puis
des conditions des très bonnes
conditions puisque on est arrivé à peu
près douze jours avant le combat donc
avec 12 heures de décalage donc on
compte à peu près
une heure une heure par jour par rapport
aux décalages
donc non j'étais très bien et quand des
conditions optimums jeff horn totalisant
sa carrière 13 victoires
un seul match nul et surtout 8 k o est
ce qu'il est si fort qu on dit non pas
du tout aller tout je pense pas qu'il
soit bon après peut-être c'est pas par
mon jugement mais voilà je pense je
pense être meilleur que lui
voilà j'ai ben j'ai bien débuté le
combat et on l'a bien vu et voilà
malheureusement c'était pas mon jour
tant pis mais ça reste quand même un bon
boxeur et un très bon coup d'oeil c'est
pas je trouve pas que c'est quelqu'un de
très puissant mais c'est vrai qu'il a un
très bon coup d'oeil et il a de belles z
sud n'est au final vous le perdez qu'au
point vous n'avez pas pris deux cas où
vous avez mis ko il faut faut y aller
pour mettre ko non non c'est bref je
suis quelqu'un qui encaisse très bien
les coups mais n'ont pas fait non il n'a
pas fait très mal mais c'est un bon
boxeur
il fallait être vigilant sur ce combat
pourrait se prendre un mauvais coup
justement pour mais fallait deux vigiles
ont assuré que vos lèvres des bons
réflexes sûrs
voilà et le fait qu'ils soient plus
petits vous également il fait un mètre
75 vous faites un mètre 82 est-ce que ça
a peut-être joué sur ce combat c'est
possible mais en vrai il paraître
peut-être de 3 cm de moins en moins en
vrai on était tous un peu impressionné
par rapport à sa taille on pensait
qu'ils étaient très petit en fait aidé
beaucoup plus grand chose je pense qu'il
fait au moins 1 m 78 mais il a une
grande allonge par contre il a des
petits bras par une fibre à mai mais il
va vite devoir
il va vite de g et du coup s qui
il met beaucoup de rythme dense dans ces
combats est-ce que bâle avait ressenti
comme ça en même temps avec mes deux
bras en moins il pouvait quand m mais je
pensais qu'il allait mettre beaucoup
plus de rythme que ça ait avancé
beaucoup plus mais en fin de compte on a
appris que voilà son entraîneur a dit
qu'il ne savait pas comment comment dire
comment aborder le combat parce que
voilà j'avais le coup d'oeil aussi jeu
c'est contré et voilà mais lorsqu'on va
vous avez également attaqué on vous
disait à l'ajustement l'instant vous
avez attaqué pendant ce combat que
défendre malgré une blessure non on va
dire que j'ai attaqué pendant quatre
années puis ensuite je j'ai fait j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu et vous n'aviez pas
boxé depuis le mois d'avril dernier
c'est ce que ça est-ce que ça a joué
finalement dans ce combat peut-être le
manque de rythme le manque le manque de
combat dans deux repaires sur sur le
ring non moi je pense pas je remets pas
je remets pas le monde de combat je ne
remets pas en cause le manque de combat
mais je pense que voilà j'étais prêt moi
j'ai rien à dire au niveau de j'étais
prêt et je remet rien en cause c'est la
blessure est elle arrivée comme
l'arrivée
et voilà j'ai fait il ya des sparrings
pour ça pour se mettre en situation de
combat et joseph en effet les anciens je
crois non vous n'avez pas lu
quelques-uns justement ça mais ça c'est
resté secret je voulais pas en parler ni
le faire savoir
ouais il ya plusieurs mois peut-être 3,4
sparring ou où j'ai dû arrêter un jeu
j'ai arrêté au premier round autres je
devais faire dire aux îles mais j'ai
arrêté un peu avant voilà il n'a eu 3-4
comme ça c'est donc pas de manque de
rythme sur l'embout non non non il
appelle compliqué très bien si je pense
que j'aurais été comme au premier round
sur la suite du combat je pense que
j'aurais gagné ce combat on va se
projeter sur la suite de votre carrière
est ce que vous allez demander une
revanche peut-être mais j'ai parlé au
promoteur était content parce que ça
fait c'est un très beau combat et puis
oui on a demandé notre manche mais lui
je pense pas qu'il soit ils soient
d'accord avec apparemment bon je sais
pas encore on sait pas mais en tout cas
on lui demandait en revanche également
de je pense pas que je vous dois hockey
et vous avez affiché de vous afficher
désormais un bilan de 22 victoires un
nul et deux défaites
du coup depuis le début de votre
carrière comment voyez-vous l'avenir
tout simplement n'a pour le moment je
vais essayer de me rétablir correctement
j'ai des rendez vous médicaux il faut
que ça nous
mon biceps droit et mon épaule gauche
parce que j'étais de chevaux de bois et
peut-être quatre mois de ses le maximum
c'est le maximum mais sinon voila j'ai
une petite déchirure au biceps droit ça
ça va
non avec un peu de créer un peu de creo
ça va peut-être que ce sera soigné au
bout de deux trois semaines
on verra à fuser de l'épaule c'est un
peu plus compliqué puisque je dois je
dois faire une un arthroscanner pardon
on verra avec les résultats
donc pour l'instant pas de date votre
prochain combat des propositions déjà
par par des étrangers et puis là c'est
plutôt au repos vacances et puis j'ai
sauvé ma blessure et coûté si ça va vite
j'aimerais bien baissé de boxer au mois
de pourquoi pas fin février
merci ahmed el moussaoui en tout cas
soigner vous bien c'est un plaisir de
vous recevoir sur son plateau on vous
suivra avec attention la suite de votre
carrière
on passe maintenant notre rubrique
handball une nouvelle défaite pour
montigny-le-bretonneux en nationale 2
féminine les filles coachées par
philippe letrange ont une nouvelle fois
perdu sur le terrain lors de la 10e
journée les îles monteyne se sont
inclinés contre colombelles 27 à 20
résumé du match et images des images
sont signés camille lambert
les matches se suivent et se ressemblent
pour montigny le bretonneux les vertes
et noires une nouvelle fois perdu au
complexe sportif pierre de coubertin
lors de la 10e journée de nationale 2
évidemment elles ont subi la loi de
colombelles score final
cette oeuvre on a beaucoup de passage à
vide on a du mal à se mettre dedans
on pêche ont dès qu'on fait une petite
erreur directe on prend un but on perd
beaucoup beaucoup de ballons plus que
d'habitude surtout en première mi temps
après on est fatigué il ya pas mal de
casse de petits bobos
donc du coup c'est difficile de passer
devant même quand on les accroche on
n'arrive pas vraiment à finir nos
actions et dès qu'on perd une balle on
sait qu'on lambel c'est une grosse
équipe
ça fait dix ans qu'ils sont en nationale
1 qui joue toujours les premiers rôles
maintenant j'attendais une proposition
méfie maintenant bon c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu beaucoup de blessés et beaucoup de
circonstances pendant le match qui ont
fait qu'on n'a pas pu rivaliser avec
elle il ya eu trop de pertes de balle
trop de mauvaises passes soit de
mauvaise réception pour on a de vraiment
donner là le ballon là
vêtements dans cette partie le coach
philippe l'étrange a dû se passer de
l'une des cadres de l'équipe la gauche
loup bénézis blessé avant la rencontre
la capitaine fanny jean baptiste à elle
dû quitter ses coéquipiers avant le coup
de sifflet final à cause d'un claquage
au mollet amandine va cesser tel tordu
les pôles des absences qui ont pesé
lourd dans la balance
on est fatigué on a besoin la trêve ça
c'est sûr après c'est ce qu'il soit
capable de jouer mieux que ça et on sait
le faire mais on n'a pas pu prouver ce
soir
cette nouvelle défaite prolonge la
spirale négative du promu montigny le
bretonneux les yvelinoises en sont
désormais à six matches sans victoire en
championnat
conséquence montigny-le-bretonneux qui
occupait la quatrième place du
classement septembre pointe désormais à
une inquiétante 10e place à 2 points du
dernier donc sont des moments difficiles
mais bon nous ce qu'on attend c'est laid
les matchs de janvier février pour
essayer de se sauver à ce moment là
prochain match pour montigny le
bretonneux le dimanche 10 janvier à
l'extérieur contre fleury loiret deux
équipes à égalité de points au
classement toujours handball mais cette
fois ci chez les hommes en prénationale
l'équipe de versailles fait match nul 25
partout ce week-end contre rennes à
domicile nous pour nous parler de cette
rencontre et du club de versailles nous
recevons sur ce bateau le capitaine dan
hier soir le gardien de but alexis
morlet et l'arrière droit à kaïs othman
et elba bonsoir alors est ce qu'on peut
dire que ce match contre away est
peut-être une contre-performance
d'amiens en sachant en connaissant votre
classement en connaissant de classement
c'est une contre-performance après sur
le match en lui même on a la chance de
ne pas le perdre sur les deux dernières
minutes aux deux gardiens pas alexis
mais dorian ne sort deux belles parades
après on commence à récupérer nos
blessés kaïs reviendra qu'en janvier
mais son grand frère qui joue aussi avec
nous est encore blessé
on a aussi un jour très important que
s'est fait opéré d'une appendicite
du coup ça ça fait beaucoup pour une
petite effectifs complets est-ce qu'il
faudra se servir peut-être de cette
contre performance pour pour voilà tout
simplement s'améliorer sur les prochains
matchs par une contre-performance si on
peut le dire je pense qu'il faut se
servir à chaque fois de chaque match
pour se remettre en question et a comme
le disait justement damiens et c'était
un match où on a récupéré pas mal de
enfin moi c'est en tout cas une reprise
de blessure on récupère tout doucement
dans qu'un certain nombre de joueurs
donc on compte vraiment sur l'eau autour
de l'ensemble de l'effectif pour se
remettre j'allais dire dans le droit
chemin
damien vous êtes actuellement deuxième
du classement après 9 journées vous êtes
descendus l'année dernière est ce que
finalement votre classement est logique
il est logique par rapport au début de
saison on aurait pu voir qu'on allait
finir promis
à l'issue de la phase aller après on a
eu comme je répète énormément de blessés
sur le seul match qu'on perd on a neuf
absents donc c'est énorme
après il est logique parce que le
championnat est vachement homogène
comparé à la nationale 3 le niveau pour
moi est plus fort dans l'ensemble que
l'année dernière l'année où on descend
même si la n est rien a énormément de
blessés c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
descend et voilà après on est deuxième
mais par ea sports que le prix
actuellement quatrièmes jeux son match
en retard du coup ci gagne pas ce
premier et on descendrait troisième mais
quelle différence justement peut-être
entre la prénationale et la nationale 3
la plus grosse différence pour moi les
sur le gardien de but où le niveau des
gardiens de but on a sauvé le 3 est
vraiment très fort parce qu'il ya à
chaque fois une paire de gardiens qui
est vraiment homogène et à chaque match
un gardien fait faire un match et puis
et puis aussi par rapport au public on a
donné la chance de jouer dans le nord la
première année où il y avait énormément
de monde à chaque fois et forcément le
public pousse les joueurs et la montée
en prénationale certains marchés nous
n'a vraiment du monde on va dire
l'extérieur ça nous avait envers le
travail juste après je le disais vous
n'êtes pas premier kaïs vous êtes vous
êtes deuxièmes qu'est-ce qu'il faudra
améliorer pour reprendre la seconde
partie de saison pour terminer premier
je pense que déjà on est partis sur des
sur des bonnes bases et faucons
qu'on réfléchisse à peut-être revenir
sur sur ce qu'on sait mais après après
je radote un peu mais c'est encore les
blessés qui est normalement de blessés
c'est dur de changer de pionner à
versailles mais en même temps c'est dur
de faire le même jeu de continuer sur la
même base de jeu le jeu rapide au début
d'année on a fait ça et c'est con c'est
dur de faire ça quand on change
d'effective camp quand on prend deux
joueurs c'est dur de continuer sur la
même même la même configuration de jeu
est votre objectif c'est de faire
l'ascenseur
cette année de mon remonter tout de
suite ça serait bien ça serait bien
c'est l'objectif fixé c'est compliqué à
dire oui ce serait ce sera un objectif
damien vous confirmer ses objectifs j'ai
de l'entraîneur après après c'est vrai
que nous on adhère même si c'est pas
facile à dire mais on va tout faire pour
y arriver
alexis on en parlait précédemment vous
comptez également énormément sur le
soutien de votre public
tout est royal vous vous ne voulez pas
les décevoir tout simplement à domicile
vous êtes quasiment intraitable basse
est certain c'est vrai que bon moi je
viens d'un autre club vient de conflent
et j'ai intégré aussi donc le groupe de
versailles aussi bien pour les joueurs
mais aussi pour ceux pour ce public et
pour ce cop qui est dans les yvelines
extraordinaire et c'est l'un des seuls
public on voit ça en tout cas ils sont
composés d'une cinquantaine de personnes
à environ ils sortent les tambours dans
les endroits les drapeaux ils nous
encouragent tout au long du match et
c'est vrai que le support du public elle
nous permet de pointer voyageant sur
l'image ouais je pense qu'en tout cas ne
reçut pas leur soutien nous permet de
pouvoir en tout cas conclure le match
positivement quoi vous le sentez ça
vraiment damien à la fin des matches là
on voit ces images de l'année dernière
où on descend malheureusement on aurait
gagné je pense que on aurait pu le rhin
leur tirer un grand coup de chapeau
malheureusement on perd d'un but à la
fin mai mais même à domicile je veux
dire le mot l'extérieur puisqu'on a joué
à mentir il ya deux semaines ils sont
sont déplacés à 10 et je pense que si on
gagne le match parce qu il soit parce
qu'on a vraiment mal joué ce jour là et
on gagne quand même donc
souvent sur des petits moments on
commence à s'égarer dans notre jeu et
nous font du bien
vous avez également changé de coach
cette année c'est alexandre taillefer
votre langue au coach kaïs comment
jugez-vous alexandre c'est un bon coach
c'est vraiment lui qui excède ce qui
apporte le petit plus cette année
ça fait déjà deux ans que je suis avec
lui donc j'étais déjà avec lui avec la
team 78 ans -18 et l'intérêt petit à
petit donc j'ai été intégré presque
directement puisque landes avant je
jouais déjà en nationale 3 du coup du
coup oui c'était c'était c'est sympa de
retrouver le même coach pour une
deuxième année
et puis pour revenir un petit peu sont
les royal blue c'est super super
gratifiant de les voir d'autant plus que
je faisais partie des royals goût enfin
je suis toujours parti des vous avez vu
quand je suis blessé et supporter je
vois super de supporters joueurs
exactement
alexis avec santé fr qu'est-ce qui l'a
porté à l'effectif peut-être ses idées
de jeu avec une progression par rapport
à un gardien ou comme je dis à mes
projets intégrés en fait le groupe cette
année est en tout cas à travers sa
vision de jeu on voit que c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a passionné qui vivent
qui vais le handball et je pense que
l'ensemble du groupe adhère à son jeu
qui est basé sur un jeu rapide et je
pense que l'ensemble du groupe a adhéré
en tout cas sûr c'est sur ces idées en
tout cas en janvier il y aura un match
très important ça sera contre plaisir du
coup les premiers du classement le
leader est ce que la montée se jouera
sur ce match là est ce que vous pensez
que la montée peut se jouer sur sur
cette victoire d'amiens non ce
ce match sera un plus pour les deux
équipes mais celui qui perdent n'aura
pas forcément perdu la montée parce que
le grand favori du championnat pour moi
j'ai dit depuis le début c'est par ea
sports club est celui qui gagne
ils sont derrière nous au classement
voilà sept ans par ea sports club est
derrière nous au classement avec un
match en retard et que s'ils gagnent ils
passeront devant nous et qu'elle était
avec plaisir du coup mais non ce match
est très important sachant qu'en plus on
a un joueur qui a été formé chez nous
qui a joué 15 ans chez nous qui joua
plaisir maintenant vous montrer voilà
que verse est toujours là exactement et
ça sera ça sera un gros match surtout
que pour la petite histoire d'amour fois
qu'on a joué contre eux plaisir d'aller
17 buts chez eux et je pense qu il
encore à travers de la gorge
donc ça me fait plaisir aussi parlé de
ce match là trois ans mercy ou toi
d'être passé sur ce plateau bon courage
pour la suite de la saison et ce match
notamment contre plaisir en janvier
merci à vous êtes passé sur ce plateau
on passe maintenant un sport insolite le
floorball aujourd'hui coup de projecteur
sur une discipline presque inconnu en
france le floorball un sport collectif
d'origine suédoise semblable au hockey
le premier club des yvelines vient de se
créer à buc roma respini à pour le
montage du ok mais son la glace et les
patins le floorball un sport originaire
de suède créé dans les années 70
débarque dans les yvelines
le club a aux bucs multisports propose
depuis septembre une section loisirs le
mercredi soir au gymnase du prés saint
jean
une première dans le département c'est
un sport qui se pratique avec une crosse
et une balle creuse avec un gain un
gardien et on joue à 5 5 contre 5 un
match de floorball ça dure trois fois
vingt minutes dont trois tiers temps de
20 minutes avec
plusieurs lignes de joueurs c'est à dire
qu'on peut échanger comme hockey sur
glace tant qu'on veut pour joe floorball
deux éléments sont nécessaires une
crosse et une balle la maîtrise de la
crosse au départ c'est pas évident faut
trouver ses marques sur sur la crosse
donc il ya une prise qui nous permet
effectivement de le maîtriser la hauteur
la vitesse même la position du corps
tout ça c'est important pour arriver à
ses fins et mettra la balle au fond des
buts donc il ya vraiment une technique
dans le floorball la balle est très
légère elle peut aller très vite par
contre quand même se prendre les balles
qui font quelques bleus mais rien de
bien méchant
cette discipline compte à l'heure
actuelle plus de me licencier en france
et une trentaine de clubs abus qu'ils
sont une quinzaine à s'être laissés
tenter par ce sport pratiqué
principalement république tchèque en
suisse et dans les pays nordiques les
gens sont curieux les gens ont envie
d'essayer on a pour faire de la
publicité on
à essayer de faire des séances
d'initiation faire la communication via
internet les gens sont venus on a une
trentaine de joueurs différents qui sont
venus l'adhésion coûte entre 95 et 110
euros le club de buc espère attire entre
25 à 30 adhérents d'ici la rentrée de
septembre 2016 et intégrer le
championnat de france la saison
prochaine
on passe à présent au football zoom sur
le club de trappes mochan a aussi le
coach de l'ol sera pas quitter le club
mardi dernier après la défaite contre où
il a été remplacé par arnaud mbc pour
nous parler de cet épisode nous recevons
sur ce bateau le président de trappes
mustapha larfaoui bonsoir bonsoir
alors la question est simple mustafar
pourquoi motion vous acquittez alors la
réponse est tout aussi ça n'a rien à
voir avec les sportifs rien à voir avec
le dernier match s'annonce passionnant
non pas d'abord il nous a pas quittés
nous nous sommes quittés d'un commun
accord
pour faire simple pour nos
téléspectateurs un moment donné il ya
besoin de trancher dans des situations
on a vu une spirale très positive depuis
le début de l'année voire un peu dire
mène depuis l'an dernier victoire
premier et puis voilà il ya eu un coup
d'arrêt
au club pour des soeurs d'effet sur
lequel je reviendrai pas mais voilà dans
une spirale positive on a tendance à
atténuer toutes les dissensions toutes
les difficultés tous les problèmes qui
peuvent être dans un club parce que
c'est la dynamique de la victoire qui
nous qui nous entraîne est qui qui
estompe le tout quand ça devient plus
difficile et plus con plus compliqué
voilà il ya des choses qui ressurgissent
et là en ce qui concerne le mode scène
il ya un élément qui lui simple à
comprendre
il vient du 93 il faisait une heure et
demie de route à l'aller une heure et
demie de route au retour pour une heure
et demie de d'entraînement en trois fois
par semaine
c'était devenu extrêmement extrêmement
pesant sur le plan familial sur le plan
professionnel
sur le plan de voilà tout simplement
très très basique on va dire sauf que
voilà il y avait des décisions à prendre
des cantons président canton président
de là pour prendre des décisions et donc
arrêtée d'un commun accord et du coup
maintenant il est disponible sur le
marché
akon entraîneur clairement et moi je le
redis je vois le recommandait je le
recommande d'autant plus que voilà c'est
un type adorable c'est un garçon qui a
apporté beaucoup
voilà je vous dise et voilà c'est la vie
déjà l'ire des entreprises l'avis des
associations la vie des clubs et la
tournée tous les gens qui préside tous
les gens qui sont dans des clubs tous
ceux qui ont participé à des collectifs
savent que des fois il ya des choses qui
matériellement sont un peu compliquées
donc on se séparent d'un commun accord
on se sépare en très bons termes et bien
évidemment ceux qui nous écoutent je le
recommence il shenzhen une écoute vous
le voulez passer un message à clermont
moi je peux nous regarder en ce moment à
ma motion si on regarde si tu nous
regardes le chêne encore une fois tu
connais mon numéro de téléphone c'est
quand tu veux il était au club depuis
trois ans est ce que est ce qu'il va
laisser un grand vide
est-ce que ça va laisser un grand vide
ce départ on laisse toujours quelque
chose de soi donc par définition il
restera quelque chose de lui cela étant
le club
doit fonctionner quelle que soit les
coaches je rappelle quand même qu'on en
a vu passer beaucoup malheureusement
c'est pas du tout ce que j'aime le plus
mais voilà le club continue les
fondamentaux du club ça reste quand même
les fondamentaux les basiques et donc
voilà c'est un club qui maintenant s'est
construit à la base et où les gens sont
relativement interchangeables si on peut
se permettre de le dire comme ça parce
qu'il ya des fondamentaux parce qu une
structuration parce qu' une organisation
il voit ce qu'est une grosse volonté
chez les joueurs en tout cas ce départ a
l'air d'avoir été digérée en écoute le
capitaine de l'équipe
hamidou sissoko oui on est triste on va
pas dire qu'on va dire le contraire
ça fait deux trois angles est avec nous
voilà après ils seront 100 fait que
alors il ya eu un changement je redis
nous on doit continuer il n'est pas
nouveau dans à ce poste-là il a
l'expérience
il connaît très bien le club donc nous
on va continuer à travailler avec lui
avant ses amis disent et ils ont plutôt
bien digérer quand même ça cette
éviction quand même ouais parce qu'il
s'agit de digérer très vite c'est dire
que c'est pas tellement le problème est
entre guillemets a été a été très bien
compris il n'y a pas de distorsion n'y a
pas de dissensions s'est passé c'est pas
un clash et la parole devant les joueurs
bien sûr comprendre sur la parole dans
ces moments là juste pour pas pour se
justifier pour expliquer donc c'est vite
digérer parce que encore une fois c'est
l'ensemble c'est le club qui l'important
c'est reste quand même
l'ensemble est le club si je peux me
permettre pour faire écho à ce qui a été
dit sur ce plateau avec notre ami elle
m'aide
el moussaoui j'ai vraiment apprécié la
tonalité de ce garçon parce que quand on
sait le type de sport qu'il fait il se
plaint pas il a passé son temps à dire
qu'il avait des meilleures conditions
c'est pas vrai quand on fait 24 heures
de vol pour aller jusqu'à nouvelle
zélande avec le décalage horaire dans
des conditions fait pareil au niveau de
la présidence si on l'a entendu parler
il s'est pas plaint une seconde il n'a
pas dit où il manquait ça j'avais une
blessure j'étais pas bien
il a justifié la chose pour les
footballeurs selon ouais mais c'est vrai
pour les pour les sportifs c'est comme
ça que ça doit si on l'entend pas
suffisamment ce type de 2,2
deux méthodes et cette façon de dire les
choses pour moi un vrai coup de chapeau
à mes démos seul on va revenir sur le
nouveau coach c'est arnaud mm bisika été
qui a pris le relais de mme stein il est
au club depuis une dizaine d'années
finalement sa nomination est plutôt
logique on écoute un juste avant de
répondre
pour nous c'est ainsi continue t 1 donc
moi je suis au club donc ça fait
maintenant plus de quinze ans de choc
l'homme non pour moi c'est juste faire
faute à coachella faire le boulot qu'on
fait depuis de nombreuses années donc
c'est pas c'est pas une nouveauté pour
moi en toi on voit sa cote chuter un
comme nouveautés de qualité donc a pas
donné par exemple changer la formule qui
gagne finalement c'était le choix
logique
c'est un choix le livre est vrai
construction et harnes busy c'est
vraiment l'homme du club c'est vraiment
le manager général et qui construit à la
ddt de la base est maintenant sûr que
c'était un homme de l'ombre
c'est un art avant c'est un homme de
l'ombre c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas
pour dire on n'est pas dans la lumière
comme je peux l'être mais qui est majeur
qui voilà qui était un élément important
je suis très très très content du
travail d'arnaud depuis des années et
maintenant à coacher l'équipe une ça
nécessite simplement une réorganisation
quand même parce que c'est la seule
organisation mais vraiment c'est presque
un mal pour un bien
et on est très sereins et on a le temps
ça se construit sur la durée du club de
foot merci à mustapha merci d'être passé
sur ce bon courage pour la suite la
saison je sais que c'est jamais facile
de changer de coacher en cours de saison
c'est la fin de cette histoire merci
d'avoir suivi genou on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine à très
bonne soirée sur tv fil 78